now that we've had this default now that
the premise of law has been passed what
happens next with negotiations with
creditors well we are we are open to
continue discussion with them the same
week the promoter was approved we was
supposed to help meet in New York but
they they decided not to have the the
middle and listen promesa is passed so
the day right now they they have another
reason to to negotiate in a voluntary
through a voluntary process something
that I have been trying to do for more
than a year without without the veil
that meeting was cancelled I gather
because they're gonna wait the creation
of this oversight board I don't know
maybe but I think that they should
prefer to negotiate with us then with
the board that that would not have the
same care for the people of Puerto Rico
like like the governor pathetic of
course and I think that they were hoping
that promise I wasn't the proof that
they will have more leverage without
promesa that with promesa now we have a
stain litigation that protect the
Commonwealth prior to promise how we
didn't have that so now we have more
leverage and in the notation with them
they choose not to demo she ate with us
in good faith prior to promesa now
promesa I think that set the table for
the negotiation with the board and the
concordant have the right to know to be
that they have been conquered they lost
now now they need to negotiate with more
leverages you say are you confident that
by January first the next big deadline
here for payments you're going to see
some sort of a solution well we have
another right that absurd the part that
the path at grow and to research grower
depth it's something that I announce
that we were unable to pay our depth
more than a year ago so so if you
remember back then David many people
said that wasn't true that we were
accelerating then they took a look at
number and saw that they were that we
were saying that the true so now with
promesa that there's no
litigation against the Commonwealth that
is possible to move forward I think that
and what we just happen in July first
day I think that that that they have the
again the set the full set of
possibilities in a head so they should
they should negotiate part of this law
is the creation of the seven-member
oversight board federally appointed
oversight board how comfortable are you
with that and how much are you going to
lobby for members of that board it's a
mixed bag in the one hand allowed us to
be protected against litigation and and
and forth the restructuring process on
the other hand intervene unnecessarily
and on a democratic institution of the
Commonwealth and and of course I do not
like that but but there was no real
choice on one side I had misery for my
people oh and on the other side I have
to choose from misery to these
unnecessary intrusion of federal
government democratic institution of the
Commonwealth it's like when someone
pointed with a weapon and ask you for
your wallet you don't want to give you
what it but and you may say no but the
consequences are worst so so it's just
that feeling a question here about the
legislation it's on your desk right now
I've got a fiscal year 2017 budget bill
you've got a two billion dollar water
bill are these pieces of legislation you
intend to sign think that you can sign
in light of the creation of this board
it's something that we are on
understudying right now that that
protect the Water Authority is will be
more likely to be sign but waits on
their study as well as others there's
some that are more like to have beat oh
and another that will be sign it but
always in a responsible way that as we
have been given taking into account that
when I was sworn in the expenditure of
the government of Puerto Rico was eleven
point nine billion dollars now our
spending sirs are being reduced to nine
point
one and we have a balanced budget so so
if I sign or veto is it will be just
driven by that